gotta tell your virginity story oh i'll
make it quick it's uh crazy i heard you
watch it
go ahead there we go comedy uh
night it was the new year's eve eve of
the millennium change so is the y2k bugs
in the air so everything was a little
kooky this is uh 1999. we might meet my
friends as you do we go down to bourbon
and uh there's a woman on the balcony
just flashing everybody you know hot
older lady kind of looked like jennifer
aniston after a fist fight you know
she'd seen a few winters
and she's like
this is pretty internet porn so it's
like you see tits you you watch
and uh she catches our eye and goes you
guys want to come up and we're like oh
my god do we try to go up they won't let
us she comes down and she goes you kids
want to throw some beads and we're like
oh i thought she was like trying to
fool around with us but turns out she's
like this very maternal thing like yeah
you kids so my friend is elbowing me
like just ask her you know what he got
to lose what you already knew like make
a move basically yeah and i was like
[ __ ] it
why you're how old are you i'm 16. okay
and i go i don't want to go to 2000 a
virgin and she goes well i won't let you
and
she brought me upstairs she opened the
door the comedy brain right then and
there exactly early on she brought me
upstairs the ramada hotel room 239 i'll
never forget
slightly autistic and she opens the door
and there's an old guy with a white
beard and a harley davidson hat leather
jacket and he goes which one is it she
points to me and he goes all right you
two to my other friends come out on the
balcony scram kids yeah he had a case of
beer out there with a cooler they closed
the balcony doors she hits the blinds
and then me and her uh just go at it for
like an hour and a half straight up your
first time hour and a half never
finished i was so nervous i panicked i
she said how do you want to do this i
said i'll take a blow job first because
i never got one of those either and she
goes i don't give blow jobs and i go you
[ __ ] kids off the street don't get
[ __ ] she hated that and she goes
anything else i go you clean she goes
you want to do this or not i said i'm
sorry and uh she she basically got naked
in front of me and i took my jacket off
you know and i was so nervous about my
junk that i i just put the dick through
the boxer hole because i didn't want to
see my balls because i was so
uncomfortable what i don't know
vulnerable and uh yeah we went to town
are you guys still in touch no she's
gotta be dead
she's in a river somewhere i'm sure
but yeah i think that was their kink
like they were a husband and wife or she
was a prostitute and she didn't charge
me but uh
she kept being like where do you live
well we should do this again and i was
like i don't want you knocking on my
door but your friends and that what kind
of conversation did they have outside so
they got out and then he opened the
doors they fell in they're like we got
sloppy second
and then i was like we're getting out of
here i felt like a wave of shame when it
all ended you know it was a lot to take
in
also i guess i'm a survivor because uh
she was older and i was 16 but i don't
give a [ __ ] i had a great day you're the
original me too movement yeah
here here well congrats bro i'm banging
this random old lady to lose your
virginity that's great lovely woman i
appreciate it if you're out there
thank you praise allah
[Music]